what's happening there citizens of the
reject Nation we're here to continue
Brooklyn Nine-Nine season 4 episode 16
today people call MooMoo
leave a like that's the most important
thing you can do please do it doesn't
take a lot of effort so go ahead do it
come on no you can I'm watching you I'm
like that annoying guy at a movie
theater commercial saying stuff to you
acting like I can actually see you when
I can't and uh let's begin this
Sarge what are the chances I say zero oh
I mean when Genevieve gotten these
suspenders I thought I'd lean into it
and go for the whole look but I didn't
want to step on your toes you know what
this means don't do this Charles oh no
oh my God who wore it best who wore it
best who wore it best Terry what Terry
always wears best yeah
not here solid
work naked the rest of the shift
cool cool so how's it going I'm still
pretty good nothing has changed I hadn't
heard about that what is happening I can
say whatever I want tell me about it I
murdered Charles this weekend I feel you
now that I have the taste for blood I
can't stop murdering been there okay
sorry what's going on why are you acting
so weird I'm gonna talk to Captain hold
about getting me more responsibility
gotta go die hard explosions whatever
hello Captain Raymond ho it is I
Sergeant Terence Jeffords your friend
but more importantly your employee I've
never heard you speak like this Sergeant
I like it each sentence so Rife with
information
[Laughter]
[Music]
one police possum is looking for a city
council liaison the application is due
tomorrow okay there's 96 pages okay okay
not including a 4 000 word personal
essay okay
I have to stay late to work on my
application I just got from home there's
six they can take the subway Rosa that's
crazy they're babies Terry just call
them an Uber oh no Shannon can't pick
him up because she's out of town with
Ava and the sitter doesn't get to my
house till 6 30. Jake and I can pick
them up absolutely oh oh boy just take
my minivan thanks guys I appreciate it
you're gonna let him drive your minivan
won't taste of practice parenting and
you two will be so hot to have sex the
kind that make babies walk away Charles
okay but yeah I'll be back in nine
months
so ridiculous
oops
who's the coolest person you've ever met
in your entire life you are and who's
the most handsome dude in all the land
even objectively more than Idris Elba
okay Jake tell them to stop we're
playing with the windows is fun Jake you
don't think science is a good fit for
them play with those windows ladies
[Music]
subtle manipulation I don't see what the
big deal is being a parent that was so
easy yeah anyone who's ever complained
about parenting has no idea what they're
doing no
pair to the ear speaking Terry baby talk
to me where the hell is MooMoo I think
Terry has a child named moo and we
forgot to pick her up oh no it's
Cagney's blankie she calls it that
because it has a little cow head she
said she had it in a minivan where is it
now
oh no no rap Dragon can't sleep without
Mumu and if Cagney doesn't sleep Lacey
doesn't sleep and if Cagney and Lacey
don't sleep Terry doesn't sleep no Jake
doesn't live oh yeah
the city leaves in 10 minutes and this
is the last thing I need okay I'm so
sorry about this Sarge oh and one more
thing I love you
I love you too Jake yes
what's going on buddy oh hey yo don't
move what the hell keep your hands where
I can see oh this guy was in Dexter drop
that
no
no uh the copson is right
yes he really was just trying to protect
the neighborhood what's wrong I gotta
stop by a cop last night stop for what
stop for walking that makes zero sense
unless oh crap I see what happened
walking while black I have no idea
what's going on you got to stop for
being black get woke Scully
I eventually told him and he finally
looked me up in the system and let me go
and I've done some pretty suspicious
things in the street
I'm just playing a prank on my buddy
sounds fun carry on
[Music]
Christmas vacation I think I just need
to sit down with the guy and have a
direct conversation you think you two
can handle watching the kids while I
meet with officer Malbec oh they can't
handle it
man uh is it because he's black uh what
do we do we can't call Tara
hmm the parental crisis you are
knee-deep in the thick Rich broth of
Parenthood
I'm already ahead of you calling Rosa
make them go to bed 6 30 p.m they're not
tired make them hang up I'll call Gina
Gina yeah Gina would know it's racism
that remains pervasive in this country
to this day Gina they're children so put
it in a song Jake racism
[Music]
looks like we're out of options unless
yes
Hitchcock and I are eating cake for
dinner and watching a movie ask Amy if
she wants to come over I'm hanging up
fake no and who wants to watch 101
Dalmatians and not ask any hard answer
questions about your father in race
noise
I'm so sorry for what happened oh I mean
if I'd known you're a copy number would
have treated you that way you're sorry
for not knowing I was a cop soda yeah
but you shouldn't have treated me that
way whether I was a cop or not
you and I both know you don't exactly
look like you belong in that
neighborhood I lived there wow I just
want you to admit you only stop me
because I'm black and to apologize and
to say he won't do it again hey look we
wouldn't even be having this
conversation if you had your badge on
you next time oh wow I'm submitting an
official Complaint with hope I know it
might feel weird to report another
officer Holt's gonna eat him for
breakfast maldek has no idea what's
about to hit him uh-oh I'm not gonna
submit this
what why not because I think it's a
mistake what holstead was worse in the
70s yeah what did you mess up the
grammar or something did you dangle a
participle oh Terry hold hates a dangler
no dangling Terry Captain Holt cares
about you more than anything I'm sure
he's got a good reason maybe you should
go talk to him about it you know go to
his house a good idea I'm going to do
that and while you're talking to him
Jake and Amy can babysit your kids ugh
are you too sure you should be
babysitting you seem real freaked when
you called me last night yes but then we
figured out how to be good parents TV
and cake tv and Cake were my parents
it's me sorry efforts from the precinct
I'm the guy whose damn complaint you
don't want to submit and I can't think
of one damn reason why everyone
oh good I'm sorry for interrupting your
dinner party no problem at all this is
important also Kevin's friend Margo's
here and she's a real class a drip sir I
can't get
that complaint could backfire cops who
blow the whistle on other cops almost
always face the backlash just like
people who socialize with Margot
invariably hear about our trip to
Scottsdale oh God
she's horrible I don't want to see your
career derailed because it was merged
for reporting on another officer there's
politics to being a cop but I wasn't
harassed to be in a cop I was harassed
as a black man I'm not saying do nothing
wow damn
action you can take is to rise through
the ranks so that you can make
large-scale changes I've had to pick my
battles and it hasn't always been easy
but now I have my own Precinct a
Precinct whose offices would never do to
you with office them out act did wow I
hear Margo's quick issues in the hallway
one guess is to where in Arizona she
bought them
I'm about to start my Scottsdale
slideshow it has
Scottsdale Market
[Laughter]
game is on okay we got chocolate
chocolate vanilla and my personal
favorite a bowl full of cake batter and
loads of movies
foreshadowing Spain black bat Roblox are
we gonna get in trouble like Daddy wow
this is a very special episode of what
kind of kids don't want to eat cake
should we call Child Services on Terry
Jake
they can talk to them for real but I'm
gonna Munch the cake batter while we do
it if you don't eat the rock fast it
makes you even more sick never mind
let's go
something called Prejudice which comes
from the Latin words pre before and
judicium which means to judge be with me
so far no no you know how it's tougher
in this world to be a woman it is oh a
cop did a bad thing your daddy didn't do
anything wrong because Daddy's black but
that cop was wrong and what he did was
bad your daddy's okay and he's not in
trouble and he loves you both more than
anything in the world okay okay huh okay
well that wasn't so bad well if you guys
have any other questions we're here for
you what's your orgasm yeah
Harry you're a great cop you can become
a chief or hire you know I became a cop
because when I was a kid I always wanted
to be a superhero stop it stop bothering
little Dickory or what or I will defeat
you no
what
whoa I wanted to help people like that
cop helped me but right now I don't feel
like a superhero who is that cop I
wasn't a guy who lived in a neighborhood
looking for his daughter's toy I was a
black man that's all he could see
threat and I couldn't stop thinking
about my daughters yeah
and our years from now they could be
walking down the street looking for
their kids moo moo and get stopped by a
bad cop and they probably won't get to
play the police car to get out of
trouble I'm gonna do
I'm filing that report even if I have
possible your head to do it
doesn't seem like you're gonna get up
and leave him because they know that
I was but I think I hear Marco
Scottsdale
the girls told me what you talked about
and it couldn't have been easy I'm sorry
I told them orgasms was another word for
oranges I panicked yeah it did make it
awkward when they asked for orgasm juice
this morning but I was more talking
about the others
oh god well they had fun and you made
them feel safe you did good they made
you a thank you card oh pretty sure my
nose isn't quite this big especially
racial sensitivity talk but
no no I came to a realization after you
stormed out last night I wouldn't say I
stormed out I shook hands with both you
and Kevin before I left all right Kevin
and I agree that you squeezed
significantly tighter than necessary
I thought a lot about our conversation
when I was a young person
I wanted to call out every bad cop I
encountered but as a black gay man I
never had a superior who was on my side
I put all my energy towards rising to a
rank where I could make a difference
exactly exactly and I realized that if I
don't back you up on this I would be
betraying the very thing that I worked
so hard for
[Music]
appreciate that captain now we both lost
our jobs no not at all you should
consider modifying your handshake it's
sending the wrong message
no it was so stressful so stressful but
like actually kind of rewarding too
shaping young minds like that felt so
powerful yeah but like so exhausting oh
yeah can you imagine doing that oh no
little shoes are so cute they're like
little circles I know I know and
everything they hold looks so big
because
yeah they have to hold a cup of water
with both hands because they're so weak
I know
that's what I'm talking about
God you ruin everything boy unlicensed
Doula I've delivered three oh yeah one
of my uncles
yes Papa's we're both off duty I think
we've earned a drink I can get behind
that I heard from the city council about
the liaison position is that right he
didn't get it oh oh this is a sad drink
um
we'll never know for sure but uh I think
it's likely however this is not a sad
drink we're celebrating
to doing the right thing hell yeah maybe
we shouldn't have filed to complaint
maybe I could have done more if I had
gotten a liaison job maybe but when
things was hurting Mal Dak will think
twice before making another bat stop
like that again
that's a win absolutely it's tough
it is so Sharon still out of town who's
uh looking out for Cagney and Lacey
[Laughter]
oh
yes
Brooklyn nine-nine's funniest episode
yes just got done that's right man a lot
like that Family Matters one yeah it's
perfect Different Strokes that's the
reference I was looking for but you you
get the point yeah man that was great
that was really it was a really poignant
episode surprisingly uh as I was
thinking in the first like few minutes
before Terry was stopped this is an
interesting kind of tone we're striking
I wasn't exactly sure how I was really
feeling about the episode yet you know
you always wait for it to find its
Groove and then when that moment
happened it did create a very apparent
shift that I'm sure everyone around the
world to watch this episode felt right
away and I thought they handled it
really well because they have to have
comedy and it's really easy for an
episode like this in particular to feel
like
the comedy is just forced because they
need to have comedy because they're
Brooklyn Nine-Nine when they're trying
to do something a little more serious
and meaningful and for the most part I
thought that they actually handled that
really well and terms of like surprising
like having a really
um you know so much of Comedy relies on
being unexpected and then having that
unexpected shift with a lot of these
comedic moments I thought was was
handled with a really nice nuance and
also uh just as development for these
characters
because it is you know in the times we
live in of black lives matter and so
much emphasis too uh and more of the
public sphere has been around for
decades at this point but it just keeps
kind of keeps rising and Rising as the
years go by uh for
um you know police brutality and
systematic racism against black people
especially with the cops and stuff so to
have an episode like this that deals
with a police officer who's black who
stopped just for that is uh interesting
interesting thing to explore over this
show because yeah I mean we're watching
Brooklyn Nine-Nine it's a hilarious
series they're dealing with
you know they're they're cops and
the conversation about cops is such a
controversial one uh these days you know
and television does a lot to glorifying
bolster cops yeah in general and you
know I've never really put much thought
into the fact that because I've explored
that with halt as a gay black man
growing up in uh I don't know whatever
but be a cop in the 70s as he was Rising
through the ranks
and I thought the way they wrapped this
around too with making this decision to
file the complaint of
in a way of of a halt overcoming some
type of uh it seems like there's a
certain level of uh trauma that he had
to endure that made him a bit of a a
hardened shell to have to persevere to
get to a point and
yet you know it's like having to go
about a new age of advancing the way
you're gonna go about with handling
these kind of problems that arise
it is easy to lose sight of that you
like you hold on so much in order to
you hold on to so much in order to
advance further in life and there's a
certain way things work
and you do strive to be like what you
know it's easy it's a lot easier it's
like you know you think about those
positions of people going If I Had a
Million Dollars this is what I would be
doing I wouldn't be doing what this
millionaire is doing like in a very
different subject matter like this I
thought that the way they made it
layered with there's a lot of a lot of
commentary a lot of things that we've
heard about lately in the past few years
and they managed to imbue it with who
the characters are at the same time so
to me I thought they accidentally
managed to have a topical episode and it
feels different because of the fact that
it was a cop himself who had to endure
uh this level of racism from another
white police officer yeah did a good job
solid yeah it's an interesting way to do
that it's an interesting way to address
you know one of the more
just says yeah as you pointed out as
time is worn on there are greater and
louder conversations about the police in
particular and you know yeah as fun as
this show is it does start to feel like
in this day and age it made me wonder
when this exactly would have dropped and
what would have been going on culturally
at the time if there had if this came
out like on the heels of you know a
major sort of police related tragedy or
not I'm not really sure exactly what the
air dates were but it feels
more pertinent than ever yeah and it
does nicely to address the you know some
people out there don't think that the
police is are a good institution
whatsoever and there are like a lot of
different ways you can approach the
conversation surrounding them and I
thought they did a really nice I thought
it was very smart and conscientious of
them to use the generational aspect and
to you know have that real conversation
of yeah doing something right now to try
and enact the change versus doing
something versus yeah like kind of
stepping back and playing it politically
and things like that and two you know
there is sort of a different
perspective now on if and how you can
change an institution From the Inside by
Rising the ranks versus you know being a
more immediate whistleblower and yeah I
thought they
I'd be curious to hear what the writer's
room was for this episode too because
yeah like you said it also didn't feel
too forced going back over to Jake and
Amy that device of them always having to
look out for the kids was an easy one to
create comedy out of but also I
appreciate that yeah I mean the major
theme of that is them trying to have
this difficult conversation with the
kids that you know their parents
arguably should be having with them but
you know for them I think too as just
sort of you know the acknowledgment you
know it shouldn't only be black folks
who have to acknowledge and have these
conversations and I think in a way
putting them with the kids and having to
explain it in the simplest terms
possible forces you to to really kind of
slow down and articulate and and yeah
like be straight and real and I thought
they handled those moments really nicely
because it is so goofy and fun and then
when it does get serious when they
finally decide to get serious it feels
like an appropriate moment and then you
know come around with the well it's an
orgasm thing and then that you know I
thought the ways they managed to bring
it back to Comedy never felt too much
like uh okay let's do some clown stuff
now you know like they still felt like
they were in the scene and uh yeah this
gives me sort of optimism that you know
once in a while when one of these more
seriously toned episodes shows up yeah
at first you might be a little bit like
huh I'm not sure uh but you know this
gives me sort of yeah just faith in the
Credence that they're able to lend these
sorts of issues you know for if anything
like this ever comes back up or any
other sort of workplace uh I don't know
if you know me too or anything will
affected the show but yeah I think it's
uh it's bold of them to have done this
on a show like this to use the platform
this way and uh yeah I thought they they
brought a lot of new ones yeah I thought
it was really well done so thank you
Brooklyn 99 team for being willing to
step aside some of the comedy to make
something that is uh very relevant and
just rises in relevancy as years go on
and it constantly feels like there's not
much changes really happening no matter
how much more
the I think the thing though too that
that's really important is you know
especially with checking on the children
that's one thing about social media
because like I said this this has been
going on for decades this is this is not
new you know and and it feels like wow
this is
this is so topical to today when I'm
like well no that today has been a today
for a very very long time
um but with social media it just makes
it you know easier to see it's easier to
see it shines a light on it a lot more
um when when there's footage out there
it really populates now and so I think
there's the one thing though about the
upcoming generation is they have a lot
more exposure to these things of
understanding and no and you know
hopefully growing up in a household that
encourages that that is wrong and I and
also to not and for people who are not
black like to be like that is you
shouldn't treat people this way so I I
think like having this be about
generations of from Holt to Terry to the
children I think is a really great call
and uh yeah but still funny at the same
time still funny all right guys well
thank you for being here uh thanks for
watching this with us glad we saw this
one and uh hey we will talk with you all
soon
foreign